hi right soon thank you everybody showed
up today everyone was crazy I mean I was
never expecting anyone to just like
you're wearing a t-shirt yeah cutoff
shorts or anything like that but you
know yeah yeah um first of all
congratulations on this thing
thank you I think you're gonna get a
whole new generation of people wanting
to be involved in this musical and
looking musicals in general it must've
been very entertaining to be on set why
I think musicals are like got this huge
resurgence in the cinema especially they
say like the only movies people are
going to watch now in the cinemas are
things starting with em Marvel movies
musicals there's something else that I
forgot but like yeah because it is like
it this is an event and this movie is
certainly like an event to go out to the
cinema and and hopefully get a lot more
people especially the younger generation
in into musicals I honestly think that a
lot of Swifty's are gonna start loving
this show that's that's the gold man
that would be awesome yeah but like a
billion people have seen this show on
stage yeah
I bet a lot of them older but whereas
like Taylor's fan bases are really young
and they'd be like what the hell is one
of the poetry set to music interesting
yeah it's very artistic and and it's
great for for kids especially to see
this kind of yeah your cat mannerisms
are specifically on point like you're
very very thanks I tried my hardest in
cat school yeah apparently Sarah just
said I was the naughtiest hat who's our
packmaster but I tried yes what is it
what is the secret to a good cat purr
ooh your lip we didn't really have to I
think I better at some point but I like
doing that with my tongue like see let
you like a cat you'll just be making
that noise yeah
yeah I mean I didn't know we learnt so
many little tricks to be the cat because
the movement is all real it's not it can
be a generator that's all from us and we
had to learn how to move in and almost
try to think like a cat weird right
much more of a dog person ality you know
like think appengine do you remember in
all of your film watching or you know TV
watching years cat characters that you
loved in shows or movies i liked this
snagglepuss snagglepuss he's like exit
stage relented it was like a
hanna-barbera character with a little
hat and you lose um
top cat which is also hanna-barbera
cartoon I loved Felix do you remember
that cartoon yes yeah yeah well guys I
gotta say it's been it was a pleasure to
watch the movie we got to see a little
bit of it that was just a CG no CG sorry
all the green screen bed okay and yeah
it was like amazing to see the the
process I want to see like the movie
version of that like I just wanna watch
it that it's it's fascinating right to
see how much the CGI is a component of
what we did but that the movie also
stands on its own just from the
performance is yeah I mean we did we
worked our butt off to figure out how to
move like cats mm-hmm
yeah and um but overall to me the I mean
the unsampled cast is awesome and but
there's something magical about this
movie and very spectacular
yeah I'm just gonna get out into the
cinema oh yeah yeah see what it is don't
don't listen to what other people say oh
you think are the trailers a bit weird
go see it and then make up your own yeah
she's magical it's perfect for the
holidays I love her
thank you so much thank you
here's the cat's cool downstairs I'm had
everything go